[Music]
Oh am I
hey who are you what's going on you're
in a coma be quiet I'm watching the
latest episode of Fargo what Fargo
so television shows the movie like
lethal weapon or training day
those are both TV show rich no I'm
talking about movies in the theater
you're talking about TV shows on
television like on trouser sticks in the
city shut the up man
those are both movies by the way which
no movies are full-length cinematic
releases like Teen Wolf or scream or
catfish those are all currently
television shows on MTV shut the up
click with me man I'm trying to
watch Argo TV shows they're
empathetically with me on television
like chips or Baywatch for play on
Joffrey movie movie movie killing me man
movies are different movies are longer
movies are things like taking Hannibal
rush hour psycho limitless shooter Wes
white shut the up asshole
God those are all teenager you know
damn it dad spit I can't deal with this
anymore shut the up I just want to
read my god damn book where's my copy of
girl on the train where is it it's
always next to me are you talking about
this why so sharing is it the
movies it all around at the ball at
the movie and guess what they ruined I
tell you it's a perfect ball they really
love ha ha ha
and I'm at the aparna hey guys you know
three musketeers in the candy bar now
guys
[Music]